it's been very hard watching Boris stage
his defense today it's
it makes for very uncomfortable viewing
David garfinkel and his family like
millions of others stuck to the rules
during the pandemic while those who made
them broke them I just don't understand
why the prime minister of our country
needs to be assured by other people
whether or not rules were or weren't
being broken
David's dad either shielded himself away
for most of the pandemic when lockdown
restrictions were eased he called covid
ended up in hospital his family couldn't
be by his side when he passed away
how does it feel
watching this kind of Defense being put
forward by the former prime minister
given the context of everything that you
and your family have been through
I think it's I think it's sickening it's
just
Soul destroying when you think about the
sacrifices that that we've made
personally in the the millions of people
made around the country
the the people running this country
didn't feel the same way about David is
now part of a support group made up of
those who lost loved ones to covid has
he said anything today that would that
would reassure you that that they that
they were doing this in good faith no
nothing nothing at all at the time when
people are dying in their thousands
every single day that you cannot
understand that you are breaking the
rules
it's just incomprehensible
is it your view that he's lying
yes I think he's
I think he's always been lying
this is one of the ways David remembers
his dad by inscribing his name on the
covert memorial wall on the South Bank
in London what makes this Memorial so
sobering so powerful is that it's
directly opposite the houses of
Parliament a daily reminder of just how
many people died during the pandemic in
the United Kingdom each heart along this
wall is a life lost and for those
families who made sacrifices who played
by the rules parties in Downing Street
rule breaking at the heart of government
is an affront to the memory of each
person who died during the pandemic
for the bereaved there are still more
questions than answers Nick Martin Sky
News